[Inaudible].
All right. People, how you doing everybody? It is November 10,
Tuesday, November 10th.
We are one week to the day from the election.
It seems like it either happened five minutes ago or a lifetime ago,
depending on, uh, your outlook on life. But it is one week ago. Uh,
we sort of have her result, kind of have her result. We have a result.
If you like the result, we don't have a result. If you don't like the result,
that and much more on today's direct message. I'm in a good mood this morning.
I have an absolutely packed day today. Uh,
I just did an interview with the Epic times.
They came here and we shot something in studio. I'm going to be on Dana.
Perino right after this on Fox news, I was on OAM this morning.
We got a couple of other things going on, just a lot. It's a lot.
And it's all good. I wake up. I've got something to do. I hope you do as well.
Uh, today the three stories that we're going to be covering,
I suspect you heard about at least two of them already.
And then the third one is just a hilarious bananas, uh, media meltdown story.
Uh, but first we're going to be talking about Mitch McConnell. You know,
Mitch McConnell, the man looks like a turtle,
but he acts like a lion. Uh,
he is not going to be listening to the Democrats who were saying that you
guys better be nice now because y'all lost. Um,
and he is ready to go all cocaine Mitch up in here, as they say.
So replay a little video from Mitch McConnell. We'll talk about that. Uh,
then of course the,
the big news today that really should supersede everything else.
Although you're not going to see much about it on mainstream media,
could it doesn't fit the narrative, um,
is that the department of justice is going to probe quote,
substantial allegations of voting irregularities.
This is from attorney general BARR,
and we will see what happens as I said yesterday,
regardless if you want it, buy it into winner Trump to win.
What you should want is a feeling of integrity in the system.
You should want any legal, legal recourse to take its action to, you know,
go to the end. And then you would want all parties,
whether it's Trump or Biden to abide by whatever the outcome is. So again,
there were the results of the election have not been certified.
Technically Joe Biden is not the president elect. The media has said that he is,
uh, there are some interesting things coming out of Michigan and Arizona and
everything where else I am not trying to send you guys down a spiral of
conspiracy theories. I'm just talking about what I'm seeing.
And unfortunately that the mainstream media isn't covering most of it.
So we'll dive into that. And then third, uh,
there's a video going viral right now. It's absolutely hilarious from MSNBC.
When, uh, one of their correspondents, he said some dirty words,
something happened and he said some dirty words and it's,
and it's just when these robotic people that we watch on mainstream,
when you actually see that they are truly humans or at least part humans,
something like that. Uh, so we'll play that.
But before we get to any event people,
are you looking for a new protein bar that tastes like a candy bar? Well, if so,
I've got just the brand for you and I'm holding it in my hand,
built bars right here. They're super tasty. They come in 18 amazing flavors.
My personal favorite, as you know,
is the cookies and cream bill bars are covered in a hundred percent.
Chocolate include both nut and nut-free flavor is under soft and easy to
chew with the holidays just around the corner. It's easy to slip up,
which is why bill bars are the perfect alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy.
I can actually lose your maintain weight while indulging in a delicious treat.
Built bars are low calorie, low sugar, high protein,
and high fiber go to bell bar.com and use promo code roof.
And you'll get 20% off your first order.
Use promo code Rubin for 20% off at built-in bar.com.
Good for bar is built, go or build the boost. And now back to me,
all right,
so let's talk about the state of politics right now. You know,
I promised you when I started this show that I wasn't going to get into the
nitty gritty of every little political fight,
because I think that's part of the problem that we are all so obsessed with
every little thing that happens politically as if every little thing that
happens politically is going to affect our lives and a good government would be
nice and tight and you could fit it in a little box.
You could wrap it in a bow and you could put it aside because it wouldn't have
that much power over your lives. That being said,
sometimes there are stories politically that do matter.
And I think that the story that matters right now, well, of course,
you've got the results of the election,
but then we do also have what's happening with the house and the Senate.
And it is important to know because you know,
when the founders set up this crazy system that we have,
they gave us three branches of government and they can check each other and they
can balance each other out.
And that makes it so that nobody can be too powerful.
And we don't end up living under a King, which is a good thing,
at least from where I sit. So let's take a look at this video.
This is from C-SPAN. This is Mitch McConnell, uh,
pushing back on the idea that Republicans need to be lectured to now about
civility and how to, how to take a loss and, and the whole thing, Mitch.
Now more broadly, Mr. President, let's not have any lectures,
no lectures about how the president should immediately cheerfully except
preliminary election results from the same characters who just spent four years
refusing to accept the validity of the last election
and who insinuated that this one would be
illegitimate to if they lost again,
only if they lost.
So let's have no lectures on this subject from that contention in late
August, secretary Hillary Clinton said, quote,
Joe Biden should not concede under any circumstances.
I think this is going to drag out and he will win it.
If we don't give an inch that same month
speaker Pelosi and the democratic leader, both stated quote,
president Trump needs to cheat to win
in October when speaker Pelosi was shopping some conspiracy theory about
the postal service. She reckless has said, quote, listen to this.
I have no doubt that the president will lie,
cheat and steal to win the election. Now,
does this sound like a chorus that has any credibility
whatsoever to say a few legal challenges from president Trump
represents some kind of crisis.
All right. People. So what did Mitch McConnell do there? What did he just do?
He used quotes. He used actual quotes,
things that people like Hillary Clinton and Nancy Pelosi have said
over the past couple of years about what happened last time.
And what's going to happen this time. I should also add that Hillary Clinton,
uh,
has repeatedly said in interviews over the last four years that the election was
stolen from her. Okay. Those are her words.
So now suddenly the same people who for four years didn't accept the results of
the election. Let's not forget.
We had basically two years of a Russian collusion hoax that led
to an impeachment scam.
And we were told we have to believe this stuff. Okay.
And that we shouldn't even question whether it's true or not.
We have to believe it.
I want to tell you a personal story in the midst of all of this,
because back in December, when impeachment was just heating up, I did,
I gave a talk one morning at a, at a turning point USA event.
And then that night, and you've probably heard me talk about this.
I actually had dinner with, uh, Trump Jr. David and I had dinner with Trump Jr.
And Kimberly Guilfoyle at Mar-a-Lago.
I know they're supposed to be big homophobes and I'm sure the place doesn't let
in gay people, but okay. It was all good. We had dinner and,
and Trump now remember, this is the middle of impeachment.
It had just started taking off. You know,
it was probably a week or two in something like that.
And Trump is sitting there in the room.
We're one table away from Trump and Giuliani was there a couple other people
were there. He was sitting next to the first lady.
And every story that day was the walls are closing.
And they're coming for Trump paranoia in the white house. He knows he's guilty.
We're going to take him out in chains, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I was looking at Trump. He was literally eight feet away from me.
He had no tie on, which is weird to see him without a tie.
Cause he's always got to tie his hair. It was like the end of the day.
So his hair was like a little lower than usual kind of floppier than usual.
And he was laughing up a storm. This was in the middle of the,
the impeachment thing. Okay. Now I mentioned that because the point is,
it seems to me that he,
that he didn't do anything and that it was going to come out to be a scam,
which is exactly what it did. That doesn't mean you have to love Trump.
It just is what it is.
So the point that McConnell is making is that these people,
the mainstream media, the democratic establishment,
they have lied to us for years because they didn't accept the results of the
election. They did everything they could to undermine the last election.
Now they seemingly got what they want.
And now you're not allowed to question anything,
which is why CNN and the New York times and everywhere else is just constantly
telling us there's no proof of anything.
Now we don't know if there's proof of anything.
There's been some interesting things that we're seeing on Twitter, right?
We're seeing some ads, evidence of something.
But if you guys won't even show us that, right, if you just dismiss it,
right. Tapper, Jake Tapper and Stelter and the rest of these guys,
if you just dismiss it and ignore it, instead of showing people,
why don't you just debunk it? But they won't do that.
They won't do that because they think it'll give it energy. But ironically,
what that does there, they're ignoring of,
of the stories that are coming out of Michigan and coming out of Pennsylvania
and everywhere else, whether they're true or not,
or whether they're widespread or not,
or if they're enough of anything to cause a reversal of a result or anything
like that when they ignore it, the average person that sees these stories goes,
wait a minute. It does seem like something here.
Suddenly 3000 votes showed up providing, I don't know.
It seems like a little and they're ignoring it. So it's like, Oh,
well there may be something is there. Cause I don't trust the mainstream media.
And in many ways,
this election is far more about distrust in the mainstream media than it,
than anything else.
Last thing that I'll say on this real quick is that it's odd
to see someone like Mitch McConnell, who comes off as you know, he's,
he's very quiet and you know, he's got, he actually has some health issues,
which is a little bit of, of explaining some of his posture and everything else.
Um, but he is actually come out. Yeah.
To be someone that seems pretty principled in this.
He's not saying you don't accept the results of the election. And by the way,
I haven't seen anyone say, you don't accept the results of the election.
Of course you say, accept the results of the election,
but let's call out the hypocrisy.
It's let the system go through the processes.
So that at the end, you know, what if turns out that the votes aren't there,
I guarantee you Trump's gonna walk, but what is he going to do?
He's going to hold up in the white house. And,
and the military is going to defend him. Like, no, that's,
that's not how it's going to work. Um,
but the idea that somehow we have to be nice right now and they ha and they're,
you know, they're reaching out and we have to be nice after what they just did.
Like I'm all for reaching out.
I think I've tried to do this show to build bridges and the rest of it,
but we have to understand the hypocrisy when we see it. Uh,
but before I get to story, number two,
I want to talk to you guys about top resume because we just did some hiring here
at the Rubin report. Our businesses are blowing up because you know what,
we're doing something decent, uh,
with today's high employment rates and uncertain future,
it's hard to plan in a bed yet alone. Look for a new job here.
The report, we understand that that struggle is real. And as I said,
we just finished hiring a new position and realized very quickly how important
it is to have a resume that stands out among the rest.
When it comes to writing your own resume,
there's an unlimited number of things that can go wrong.
And the cost of those mistakes can be a missed opportunity to secure your dream
job.
Top resume is the world's premier resume writing service writing and analyzing
more than 4 million resumes and LinkedIn profiles. Every year, top resumes,
professional writers will create a resume that showcases your talents,
achievements, experience, and career goals.
Using keywords and skills that recruiters are seeking top resume also
offers a free resume critique service, including confidential,
comprehensive review from trusted experts.
Objective feedback on how well your resume communicates your skills and
expertise and personalized recommendations on how to make your resume stronger.
Go to the pros to get the job done, right?
Let the experts at top resume work with you to create a job winning resume that
gets noticed. Find out how to get your, find out how your resume stacks up.
Go to top resume.com/ruben to get a free resume review.
It's as simple as uploading your resume to their site and you'll get a free
evaluation and expert advice on how to make it stronger.
Top resume is also giving my listeners 15% off their professional resume writing
services. So go to top
resume.com/ruben today for your comprehensive resume review and 15% off
resume review writing services.
If you want to work with a pro that's top resume.com/rubin.
And now back to me, all right, so attorney general,
Bob BARR, as they're saying on the Twitter he's been activated.
So what is happening right now? Well,
the department of justice and that's the department that the attorney general is
in charge of,
he is now decided to do a probe to quote,
check back the substantial allegations of voting irregularities.
So let me get it the, the exact quote, because I'm a hell of a journalist.
Apparently, even though I don't consider myself a journalist, this is Bob BARR.
He said, uh, I'm sorry, this is from the associated press,
the Trump administration through the presidential transition into tumbled on
Monday, uh,
attorney general William Barr authorizing the justice department to
probe allegations of voter fraud and president Donald Trump firing the Pentagon
chief and blocking government officials from cooperating with presidents and
elect Joe Biden's team. Okay.
So to basically unpack this Bob BARR, you may remember the video,
maybe we'll even cover this tomorrow, but you know, we will cover this tomorrow.
Uh, there is a video from,
I think it's about two or three months ago where Bob BARR was being, uh,
there was a Bob BARR, it's bill BARR, it's bill bar, bill bar.
I got bars and I got bill BARR. I keep calling him Bob bar, bill bar, sorry,
guys. Uh, there's a video from about two months ago when bill BARR,
William bill BARR was on CNN and he was being interviewed by Wolf
Blitzer about voter fraud and voter irregularities and what he would do and how
mail-in ballots are changing things and offer more, uh,
room for malfeasance and all of that. And there's a really interesting clip.
It's probably about a minute or two. We'll play it tomorrow, uh,
so that you can actually see the clip,
but he was warning that there could be fraud.
And of course there can be fraud in any election.
I suspect if some of the things that we're seeing right now,
we saw in some election in Eastern Europe,
say Ukraine or some election in North Africa that we might say, Oh,
maybe something weird went there and the media would be running with it. If,
if the media didn't get the result that they wanted. So in essence,
what bill BARR is doing, who's Bob BARR. I don't know who Bob BARR is.
Wasn't there was there a democratic politician named Bob BARR long time ago.
He kind of looked like a mouse. He had a little mustache,
can we Google Bob BARR? I think there was a guy named Bob BARR. Uh,
but in any essence, in any event, bill BARR, uh,
is going bill bar exam. It really bill bar right there.
Um, they're gonna look into it now that doesn't mean that they're going to do
anything. And by the way, by looking into it,
that would then if you've got 70 million people who were just going, you know,
something ain't quite right and we don't trust them mainstream media,
well then looking into it, letting things go to the courts where then, you know,
it's very hard to fake the data.
I actually have talked to a couple experts on this and a couple people really in
the know about elections and what virtually everyone has said to me is it's
very,
very hard to fake the data in a way that wouldn't be obvious if you're faking
it. So by the justice department,
looking into these allegations, well,
then they'll get to get the papers in front of them.
They're going to look at the numbers and then they have all sorts of math
equations and everything else that they can look and they can see,
is there something really wacky here like did a hundred thousand votes show up
at 3:00 AM for one candidate and nothing for the other candidate that would be
odd, but they know what they're looking for.
And letting the justice department look at this,
I think is absolutely completely fine. And then by the way, as I just said,
at the end, you get to the end of it. And at the end they go, you know what?
We didn't find anything. We did not find anything.
Or we found some things that were inconsequential,
or maybe we found some stuff in one state.
That's not enough to change the results of the election or whatever it is. Well,
then you've let the process play out.
But what I'm seeing right now from a lot of people,
a lot of people sort of in the skeptic community and generally people who,
who are sort of, um, I would say skeptical of power, right?
Suddenly everyone's saying, no, we can't look at anything.
We can't look at anything.
And that's what the mainstream media is pushing on you.
And that's what Twitter will sensor and everything else. So all of these things,
I mean, again, all of the things that we always talk about here,
they sort of widdle into how are you as a
person supposed to figure out what is true in the mix of this.
And the answer to that is it is freaking difficult.
It is just really difficult to do because we've got a media that ignores stuff.
We've got a media that pushes stuff, and it's all dependent on,
on who's in power. As I talked about with the previous story, uh,
but speaking of our mainstream media,
I saw this video this morning on MSNBC.
This just went viral about an hour ago. And I, I said to my producer, Michael,
this morning, you know, I don't,
I don't want to just drop everybody with politics today. You guys know,
I try not to do that in general,
but I wanted to find something like a little more lighthearted or silly or beat
or whatever. Now this is MSNBC. So it is sort of political,
but I think you're going to see why I thought this clip would be just right to
end the show today. This is MSNBC. This is Craig.
Melvin is a,
is interviewing a reporter by the name of Ken
Delania. And, uh, well, take a look.
As some new reporting on something that we talked about at the top of the hour,
how the Trump administration is handling the transition with the incoming
Biden team or not handling. It was,
should say to a certain extent this time it involves our intelligence community.
Uh, Ken, what have you learned, sir? Oh.
Okay. Uh, think we lost. I think we lost kid for a second. We'll try it.
Oh,
the media just became self-aware you see that? Ken, Ken,
what have you learned about this thing that we're constantly talking about?
What was the.
Um, I don't know exactly what happened there and I'm gonna,
I don't know who Ken is. I've never seen Ken before,
but I'm going to give Ken the benefit of the doubt that maybe something weird
happened with his IFB.
That's the little thing that you put in your ear so that you can actually hear
the feed. Like I have it in my ear right now,
not so that someone can tell me what to say or anything like that,
but it's so that I can hear the clip. Right.
So I could hear that MSNBC clip because we can't play it through my speakers in
here because I've got a microphone on and it causes reverb and a whole bunch of
other things.
So I'm going to guess that maybe something happened some weird crackling or
something. Uh, but there's just something sort of beautiful about like,
you know, watching Craig Melvin's, you know, in effect like,
so when we don't know what the hell is going on,
Trump may acknowledge something may not acknowledge. Oh.
Like, it's just perfect. And there's also something about, you know,
I talked about this a lot about like seeing these mainstream media
people that in fact they are human, you know,
you only see them in little box. Right. And they act very serious all the time.
And th you know, they're very self-righteous and very moral and, you know,
they've got their, their glasses and the rest of it.
And yet the truth is that they are people, you know, but,
uh, [inaudible] breaking news. Virta, it's like,
I think that's why so many people are just tuning out of this because the
act we've, we've sort of seen through the act, you know what I mean?
We've pulled the curtain aside and it's not the great wizard of Oz. It's just,
you know, this little guy, this little nervous scientists like that,
that's sort of where we're at with everything right now. So it's just, it's,
you know what, let's play the clip again. Can we, Connor,
can we get that thing going again? I, I need to see it one more time. I said,
I've got a busy day today, but I feel like this will set me up. Right?
So let's throw to the clip one more time.
This is Ken Delaney and responding to Craig Melvin
on Ms. NBC.
Has some new reporting on something that we talked about at the top of the hour,
how the Trump administration is handling the transition with the incoming
Biden team or not handling it.
We should say to a certain extent this time it involves our intelligence
community. Uh, Ken, what have you learned, sir?
Oh.
Okay. Uh, I think we lost.
I mean, the way that Craig ocean, you know, okay.
I think we lost Ken or Ken or whatever. I like this though. Oh.
That should be, that should be an MSNBC show. You know what I mean?
Like right after your bad out, you know, and then she has to like, you know,
give them the transition into, Oh. So, you know, she's babbling to the camera.
Russia, Russia, Russia, Trump, Trump, Trump coming up next on. Oh.
We're screwed everybody. I think that would actually be, I would watch MSNBC,
if that would happen. I would watch MSNBC. All right. People,
I got a crazy day ahead. So I got to jump I'm on Dana.
Perino in about 10 minutes on Fox news. So you can check that out. And, uh,
I was just on OAM this morning. We got a couple other interviews, uh,
and then we're going to be doing a live direct message from Dallas on Thursday
and a couple other surprises on the way. So check it out. And as always,
if you want to communicate with me directly, don't trust the big tech overlords.
Join us at my locals community. Uh,
at Rubin report.com have a great day. Everybody.
The adventure continues. We'll be back tomorrow.